I was I was thinking she's just very
very Miser misinformed very ignorant and
you know she has this like um she's
obviously been like highly influenced by
extremist groups and so all her points
were just kind of in that line of just
like I experienced I know someone who
experienced this therefore it's an issue
for society
um I didn't like how she dismissed men's
issues because I thought that was very
kind of uh she kind of threw herself
under the bus there where if you claim
you care about equality and women's
rights and then say men's rights Miss
Andre is a pity party is kind of like
extremely
extremely ignorant so yeah
what did you think of the clip in my
opinion um I feel like she's been for a
lot of things because for her to talk
like that she has experienced a lot of
things when it comes to men so that's
why that's why I can't judge of what
she's saying and I'm saying because I I
from my experience I've been around a
lot of people when they tell me their
stories about it could be about a guy or
female but the way to go into it I
deeply listen to it so hard and I can
just tell like they've been going
through a lot so for her to talk like
that I can't judge because she's she's
hurting and I can just hear in her voice
she's hurting that's why I ain't judging
that she looked like she wanted to cry
100
can I yeah go ahead I mean I'm sure she
was pretty hurt like you can actually
tell that she's gone through some sort
of rough experience however
I maybe like Alex think that she's those
kind of people that would manipulate the
information for you to take the message
the way she wants you to have it does
that make sense and that is where you
lose that you know understanding because
the statistics went from every other day
for every three days and then one year
and then three years Gina is like taking
the same issue and then molding it to
favor your point of view so that is not
fair because it has to be objective like
I don't know that's how I feel about it
but it's clearly that she's gone through
some rough experiences
um can I say something I think obviously
she just represents some of the biggest
problems that we have nowadays it's just
where people are talking without having
the capacity to be talking on the topics
they're talking about that's why she
misused statistics that's why she missed
she didn't quite make a coherent
argument however the sentiment and the
words that she's trying to say I fully
sympathize and actually kind of
agree with what she's saying yes there's
the most advanced towards men yes yes
yes yes but traditionally culturally
socially politically economically
Everything Lee women tend to kind of be
the ones on the losing side and I say
that not just from my own experience I
say that from my own research into this
I say that for my own like life
experiences you know the people how yeah
and the losing side of the topics that
she's talking about of course think
about it even in in Latin America for
example in Africa in Asia there's a lot
of women that die in the hands of men
and that even though that's outside of
Europe and the world that we live in
that's just another example of how
actually the world is some more like can
we stick to the West even in the west
even in the west is the same thing like
if I'm gonna I'm not gonna lie I bet you
that if I walk even let's say just
London if I walk around London and I
asked a few girls like has a man ever
slapped you a lot of them will say yes
how do you have a H because how do you
know they didn't deserve to be a slap
though but but that's not even and
that's again the deserving deservings of
uh to slap somewhere somebody deserve to
be slapped that's subjective again most
abuses is mutual meaning both parties
are hitting each other so a lot of girls
will hit guys often first and then claim
and cry abuse when he hits back but you
hit him first yeah okay and and most so
um they looked at abuse abusive
situations and the ones that are
one-sided which means one party's
hitting the other and the other is not
returning women are more likely to do
that than men okay I understand that
completely I've been in that situation
before of course I hit that because I'm
not here to take slaps for no reason
right but it still remains like the fact
that even for and this goes to your
question should women fear men right A
man is way stronger than a woman you get
so why are you even hidden in the first
place you shouldn't and yet they do are
more race than women do and some yes guy
victims some of them can cause the
situation but let's not run away from
the fact that there's a lot of women
that are actually victims to the toxic
masculinity that is out there
a toxic masculine go ahead Auntie
[ __ ] word that's what I can say
somebody that's been in an abusive
relationship [ __ ] what's she saying
[ __ ] as far as I'm concerned she's
going from one side
she's going from one side she's going
she's if you go onto the internet and
you look for women who have been abused
you're gonna get one set of figures what
about the men that have been abused
there's men out there that have been
abused that are being abused there was a
um I think there was a program I think I
mentioned it when I saw the shows there
was a guy and he almost lost his life
through being with his partner
how many of these how many men suffer in
silence a woman will go out there and
she will slap a man
right and if the man goes and calls the
police is the police going to come and
arrest him and take him is that going
down as a statistic and I'm not even
defending a man because as far as I'm
concerned no one deserves to get hit but
you've got to be fair about it a woman
will turn around slap a man and I'm
talking I've seen it happen I know if it
happened a woman will turn around slap a
man call the police if the man slaps
about and they will take the man how
many men out there are getting slapped
by women and that will call the police
and say this woman slapped me how many
men are going out women are too so quick
to easy and turn around and say oh I've
been abused how is it for a man if I'm F
women if that society would accept that
men get abused they will speak up more
and then you'll see the statistics
change so as far as I'm concerned all
that talk about we should fear men and
whatever I've been battered by a man I
do not fear men because that is a rare
occasion that is a rare occasion that is
rare I'm not gonna go around and say oh
because I got abused all women out there
were getting abused because I know that
men get abused out there and it's not
publicized and if there were statistics
for men I'm not defending anybody
getting abused but you've got to be fair
about it and as far as I'm concerned she
don't even look like she suffered she
looked like she's been around people
they feather this go on the internet
sometimes you need to turn off the
internet and use your brain and all
she's doing is getting her information
from the internet and from she looks
traumatized go and get counseling girl
or something like that she reminds me
I'm just going by the way she looks I
don't care whether people hate me she
looks like a plain bitter feminist
lesbian nothing about her says nothing
about her says I'm sorry I'm gonna say
nothing about her says feminine nothing
about her says oh this is what's going
on she just looks like she's on one
agenda and that's the way she was going
so I'm getting tired of hearing that oh
this is what happens to women I want to
hear what happens to the men because the
men out there are suffering in silence
and it's because of society that men do
not speak up men do not speak up because
they're so busy Easy Feeling fearful
that they're gonna get called a beta oh
how can you let that woman slap you or
how can you let that woman stab you up
this man they're suffering but because
of society they're not saying nothing so
if they're going to turn around and say
oh what she's saying is right oh is your
fair man [ __ ]
100.
but I still remain it's true some men
suffer I get it but let's not why do you
always have a response I do have a
response because I've got a lot of
experience actually speaking
that's word number one and I'm here to
help you boys about get onto you don't
he's a man not a boy no he's a boy for
him to say [ __ ] you two more [ __ ] this
to a woman like me that thing he has not
just your words I said [ __ ] I said
I'm an African woman I'm proud of
Heritage I said [ __ ] and you never
had the attitude towards me no because I
respect you you're older than me he's
younger than me
of course but then the respects also
comes from the fact that you respect the
fact that somebody has been on this
Earth longer than you so they know
things you don't know so you're moving
on so what you said was rude and then
secondly I will say it's not that women
should fear man because actually I think
you as a woman you can have ways of
dealing with those situations but I'm
not going to run away from the fact that
yeah men get abused but women on the
losing side on that one how are they on
the lose I'm not gonna lie I'm so sorry
how are they on the losing side if if
women can call the police and they're
unbelieved but men can call the police
and they're not cool because the reason
why I say we're on the losing side is
because they still we're getting you
know how many women suffer in silence
you can't be sitting there and acting
like yourself I would say not many with
the amount of girls that have come on my
show and and claim to have been abused
even though they didn't seek police help
right I would say not many I would say
most girls if they suffer they tell the
whole town about it you asked me and I
told you I didn't find a report why not
why not I didn't because I just feel
like you know why not why not make him
look bad even don't make him look bad
rubbish you're saying that somebody else
hit you somebody's gonna do something
bad but it's different why do you think
they're not [ __ ] to the men who
don't report the fact that they get hit
by that yeah
of course I hit him back because of your
time
but at the at that point there's a
difference I hit him back that would be
self-defense and then two the way that
he hit me is nothing compared to how he
how he how I hit him and that's what the
difference is and I see each other
you're abusing each other and then wait
and then let me bring you another
another example I stayed quiet not
because I'm embarrassed but I stayed
quiet because coach really actually what
happened to me wasn't really that bad so
you just left it open for somebody else
to get abused by that same person that
abuse you because you never reported you
just assume now that you're gonna help
her a brother stop a brother from going
into prison and you're gonna help him
out it is
[ __ ] that is why for real people
that is why no because you're him to go
out there and traumatize somebody else I
get sick and tired of people turning
around and saying I've been abused I've
been abused I've been abused if you can
stand up and say I've been abused why
didn't you go police I went police why
don't you go police why don't you file a
report and then you're gonna turn around
and then you've got the audacity to turn
around and say well if that's the case
and I never reported it let the man
stand there in silence I let the men
suffer that's wrong and I'll tell you
another reason submission is another
problem why a lot of women get hit too
listen right violence has got nothing to
do with submission violence has got to
do with somebody feeling that they've
got more power over somebody else
whether it's a woman that turns around
and slaps a man in his face she feels
you know what I've got more power
because yeah I slap you and what what
are you going to do about it what is
society going to do about it nothing
let's turn down nothing don't men
usually be in the in a superior position
which means that my point just stands by
what you told me just okay
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and and we are demonetized on
a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible